so Marvel came out with New Avengers
infinity war posters earlier this week
and a lot of you have been asking what I
think of them and if I think they mean
anything so I did a brief video on the
New Avengers infinity war posters before
we dive into these awesome posters it
would be super awesome if you tap that
little subscribe button there you know
you want to it really grows on you
doesn't mean I really like the posters I
do I think they're done very well I like
the color scheme that they have going on
I'll talk a little bit about what I
think that means in just a bit I like
how they accent certain characters and I
like how individually the posters show
the individual teams that we'll see in
the movie but together they have all the
Avengers except for a certain arrow
shooting somebody who might be a ninja
in the next movie I do so one thing
these posters do show us are the teams
that the Avengers are going to be in for
infinity war after Civil War the
Avengers were essentially dissembled and
divided we saw Captain America show up
to the prison where some Avengers were
being held at the end of civil war and
it's likely that he broke them free but
we have no idea where they are right now
and we know that they're going to have
to come together if they want to stand
any chance to defeat Thanos and they're
adding some new people to the team such
as Doctor Strange long black panther and
the guardians of the galaxy the teams
that they're put on in the posters don't
really reveal too much new information
to us we've seen these teams and the
Entertainment Weekly photos that were
released and the trailers that we've
seen so far we've seen Iron Man Doctor
Strange and long together and we've also
seen Iron Man and spider-man together as
well we've seen Black Widow Black
Panther Ikoyi and the Hulk running into
battle and we'll condit together and of
course we've seen Thor in the guardians
of the galaxy together when the
guardians find Thor in mid-space
and bring him aboard the Milano we've
also seen Wanda aka The Scarlet Witch
vision Falcon and war machine together
when they get off a ship in what Conda I
think it's safe to assume that they were
together before they went to Wakanda and
they'll definitely be together when all
the fighting takes place this next
posters team however is a little
interesting we've obviously seen Captain
America and good old Bucky Barnes
together
or as he's going by now the white wolf
please don't know what it gives me but
we haven't seen this team of Captain
America Bucky
Shuri nebula and mantis together yet
obviously Captain America goes to
Wakanda which is where Bucky and Cherie
are and we've seen nebula fighting in
Wakanda as well
but how did mantis get there in the
clips that we see of her in the trailers
she's with the guardians of the galaxy
each time her and nebula fought together
in guardians of the galaxy vol 2 so I
guess when the Guardians split up into
their teams she goes to earth to help
fight Thanos I'll be excited to see what
other guardians of the galaxy go to
Wakanda so besides the teams that
they're in what else is pretty
interesting is the colors the colors
that are shown in the posters are
actually the colors of the Infinity
stones that we've seen so far red for
the reality stone green for the time
stone blue for the space stone purple
for the Power Stone and yellow for the
mind stone and of course we have not
seen the soul stone yet but again these
colors could just be referencing the
main Avenger on each photo red for
Ironman green for the Hulk
blue for Captain America yellow for
vision and purple for the guardians of
the galaxy and Thor the colors might
mean something or they might not mean
something everyone do you think they're
related to the Infinity stones somehow
but at the same time I don't think
Doctor Strange would give that Green
time stone to anybody in the green
poster but then again for the greater
cause what do you guys think do you
think these colors mean anything or do
you think they mean nothing let me know
in the comments below
and either way they're awesome posters
for a movie that we've been waiting for
for such a long time and we get in less
than a month be sure to LIKE the video
and please subscribe to my channel to
stay up-to-date on Avengers infinity war
Marvel and all things superhero thank
you so much for watching guys woof woof